hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my Walking Dead episode 6 video
all Carol all Daryl totally explained
what happened up to the moment Daryl
came back to the church after the
Abraham episode last week I thought they
might be jumping backwards in time we
also found out what Carol was doing
between the time she left Rick and
season 4 and came back to save them I
think the most exciting thing though is
the last couple of minutes it basically
explains what the finale is gonna be
quick reminder new round of the giveaway
starts now all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video
careful for spoilers from the episode if
you haven't seen it yet starting with
top five moments number five Carol's
backstory so just like Abraham's episode
last week the episode jumped between
present day in the past
it broke Carol's backstory up into slow
pieces from right after she left Rick
crying on the way down the road all the
way up to the minute that she saw the
prison fire then finally right after she
rescued them from terminus or help them
escape it was really interesting in this
episode that she said I think that we
don't get to save people anymore I'm not
sure that she believes that I think it's
a situation where she cares way too much
about the people in the church that's
why she was trying to leave when Daryl
Cotter
I think she's just so worried about them
that's why she was so quick to try and
kill Noah by the end she had totally
come to her senses too like they
completely flipped positions Daryl
wanted to leave Noah behind she wanted
to save him so she's not too far gone
despite being hit by car I feel like
that's a good PSA for looking both ways
before you cross the street seriously if
you have a child just show them that
scene number 4 surprise its Noah on the
run if you're confused about the
timeline
he ran into Daryl and Beth for the first
time right after he escaped from the
hospital a couple of stray observations
during this scene one probably never
gonna want to go camping again to never
try to steal Daryl's crossbow it will
not end well when Noah got caught under
the bookcase did anyone else get a
flashback to Bob in the grocery store
like whatever the liquor case fell on
top of him it's almost like karma was
punishing them for doing something
really terrible karma in this case being
Daryl such an action hero dude moment
when he lit that cigarette after taking
his crossbow back imagine what would
happen if he tried to steal the poncho -
Daryl would have pushed him out a window
the minute no appeared it was pretty
clear what the end of the episode was
gonna be we knew carol was going to
end up captured in the hospital and we
knew Darryl was gonna be back at the
church with a mystery person the big
question was just how Carol ended up in
the hospital whether she did it on
purpose or whether it was an accident or
they captured her I guess you can
consider getting hit by a car to be
halfway in between they're like she
didn't do it on purpose but they didn't
capture her so many Everybody Hates
Chris jokes in here it's not all bad he
has the information that Darryl and the
survivors will need to get Carol and
Beth out of the hospital number three
WTF van ride over the bridge
another great PSA for wearing your seat
belt it's a new goal of mine now to
petition AMC to make that car right over
the bridge part of the AMC Walking Dead
experience next year at Comic Con
I would totally sign a waiver for that
in a heartbeat such an awesome Thelma
and Louise moment for Carol and Daryl
the crash also teased up the Carol Hurt
storyline like she's gonna need some
sort of care if you notice she actually
her wound was basically in the same
place that Bob's was whenever he got bit
like he got bit like I think right
around here anytime any of the main
characters gets like really badly
wounded on the show you always wonder
what's gonna happen it's like I don't
think they're gonna die but at some
point they're gonna have to deal with
that giant gash that's actually one of
the big conversations about Abraham
that's still going on like his hand
wound number two
comparing old Carol and Daryl to the new
versions it's been a long time since
season 1 so hopefully everyone has
evolved as a character sometimes people
backslide but it was awesome to hear
Carol sort of recap her life as well as
Daryl's he used to be a boy now he's a
man pretty simple Carol a little bit
more complicated
that's just why she's one of the more
interesting characters the most
messed-up ones are always the most
interesting speaking of messed up did
you see that Daryl stole that book about
childhood abuse that's a nice callback
to the episode with Beth where he talked
about his childhood I think it was
implied in that episode I think we kind
of understood that his parents abused
him or his dad did I can just see
everyone crying if we find him reading
it later
poor little Daryl it's the same story
with Carol they're both victims of abuse
think about what Carol said though the
Carol that she used to be just kept
getting burnt away the original Carol
like season 1 Carol or pre season 1
Carol with Sophia who just went back to
her husband Edie
and kept getting abused she was burnt
away cut to the prison she gets to be
like a normal person someone she thought
she could be things go sideways that
Carol gets burnt away and now she's just
not sure who she is she's like almost
too fried she has to find a way to
evolve or dive
matter has two states of existence
growth and decay or in this case growth
or Walker fingers crossed that this
version of Carol does not literally get
Burt away in the finale and my number
one WTF moment of course Carol gets
taken to the hospital and Daryl forms a
plan I don't think the police officers
intentionally hit her I think they were
just going really fast that is why you
must always look both ways before
crossing the street
especially if you're on a television
show so fast forward to next week what's
gonna be happening now just like last
year probably gonna be a two-part finale
so part 1 will be the attack part 2 will
be the resolution they have a lot of
people and a lot of guns so do we the
fact that they showed Abraham's group in
that teaser - is kind of interesting
right now they either have to turn
around and come back or they have to
move on to DC last year after the
mid-season finale
everyone was split in all different
directions I don't think they're gonna
do the exact same thing that's why I
think that their group is just gonna
continue on to DC option B though is
that they could run into the survivors
and help out during the finale just to
talk about the biggest rumors I've seen
so far
one is that Carol dies sacrifices
herself from Beth the other big rumor
that Beth dies obviously both rumors
talking about someone big dying I
haven't seen any spoilers so you'd have
to worry about that but I think the
Walking Dead has finished filming the
last half of the season or at least they
have had their wrap party I'm not quite
sure how far ahead they film but I think
that they're done with all 16 episodes
at this point because usually they start
filming in the summer the really fun
thing I don't know a lot of you guys
don't celebrate Thanksgiving because
you're in international countries but
here in America we have like a big
Thanksgiving holiday Walking Dead is
like right after that so I am very
thankful for that in advance so it's
totally subtext but I have to address
Carol and Daryl I have to address that
ship in this episode the minute they
landed in that bed together I saw so
many pictures post on Twitter I feel
like if you want them together this is
the closest you're ever gonna get like
they're never gonna consummate that
relationship The Walking Dead is not a
hopeful show it is a tragedy they should
just call it the walking tragedy I know
that's
kind of pessimistic but I feel like the
characters just do not get a happy
ending yeah if you could live long
enough eventually the walkers would die
off but it's not a hopeful show although
there are hopeful moments let me know
that what was your favorite moment from
the episode and what do you think that
their plan of attack is gonna be
whenever they come back to try and get
Beth and Carol out I feel like it's
gonna be a reverse version of what
terminus was like they left terminus
after creating this big explosion I feel
like they're gonna create some sort of
big explosion and then run in although
Rick in the teaser talks a little bit
about catching them by surprise
really like the options are infiltration
like really stealthy infiltration or
just smash-and-grab overall though I
gave the episode a solid 8
totally loved Carol and Daryl - the most
interesting characters in the show of
course the episode that focuses on them
would be one of the best ones of the
season they also have the benefit of
being the episode right before the lead
up to the finale or the finale itself
consider it a two-part finale there's no
way that episode is gonna be a downer
just in general I feel like they've done
a much better job in season 5 of
building the tension which each episode
season 4 part 1
felt like such of a dead zone in terms
of action that you just weren't quite
sitting on the edge of your seat
whenever we got to the governor's attack
on the prison I mean yeah it was a holy
[ __ ] moment but I feel like we were kind
of blindsided with it this season is a
little bit like that van ride over the
bridge teetering on the edge and you
know what's going to happen like you
know it's gonna fall
so you just winced and wait for it to
happen let's all hope that the
characters limp away at the end just
like Carol and Daryl there's always the
question about whether or not the
Walking Dead needs to kill off
characters they said they killed Hershel
off because he felt like such a safety
net like a place of safety for the
survivors at the prison the riders of
course want to take that safety away
from them so they yank Hershel out from
right underneath them I do kind of see
Carol as that kind of character right
now and she feels almost invincible so
if all the people that could die during
the finale I feel like she's at the top
of the list it's like the more powerful
you are the bigger target you are in the
writers room so some things to look
forward to next week big Carl episode
looks like he's gonna try and force a
weapon into Gabriel's hand don't think
it's gonna go well also during the
episode there was a commercial with a
Morgan scene from season one I feel like
that's foreshadowing that he's gonna
show up in the mid-season
at some point could be episode 7 could
be episode 8 but I definitely think he's
gonna show up somewhere and if you
remember the last time we saw him he was
armed to the teeth just a clear sign
that [ __ ] is gonna go down be sure to
subscribe to get my video I'll post it
right after the episode airs next week
in the meantime you can click here for
the Q&A video I have the annotation as
soon as I post it tomorrow and you can
click here for my episode 5 video thank
you so much for watching so let's all
high five and say a prayer for Carol